My background was quite challenging.
I grew up on a council estate,
single parent family.
I was born
with a physical disability.
Regardless of your background,
if you really want to achieve
something, you can.
So my first tip would be...
So the challenge that I would have
when I was playing,
was that I'd make a mistake quite
early on
and then I'd spend effectively 60
minutes worrying about
what I'd done in the first 10
or 20 minutes of the game.
I would dwell quite a lot,
and it would affect me
to the point where
at half time I'd get subbed off.
And that's the worst thing.
But when you make a mistake, just
think forward, look forward,
think about what
you're going to do next
and that will take you away from the
previous error.
So my next tip would be...
When I was born I was born with a
physical disability called clubfoot
so it's basically
where one or both your feet
are completely turned all the way in.
So it got corrected
but my foot still has a sort
of slight angle in when I run.
Over my career I think I've had
many times when I've had a bit of...
I guess, self-doubt,
very negative thoughts,
I really needed to work
really hard on that mental side.
So I came up with my mantra -
I'm fit, I'm fast,
I'm athletically strong -
so it was all about me being
confident in my body.
Before I played in a big game
I would say to myself that mantra -
right that's me, I'm going to do it,
I'm going to show
people how good I am.
So my next tip would be to...
By that, I mean it's important
that people set goals
and when you write it down
it really does focus your mind
and focuses your behaviour.
And I think what's good
about having a structured diary
is that it allows you
to be organised,
it allows you to feel good about
yourself when you've done it,
monitoring your progress
allows you to improve.
So my final tip would be...
I think it's important to recognise,
prior to a game,
or prior to any big event,
that you're going to deliver,
giving yourself time to think about
what you're about to do.
Early in my career, I wouldn’t
give myself that time and space
and I'd just go into a game
almost like a headless chicken
because I'd be so excited,
and then as a result of that
in the first 10 minutes
I'd give away a penalty.
So I'd always say to people,
where possible, switch off.
Prior to a big game I like to take my
dogs for a walk, I've got two dogs,
and that allows me to feel
quite comfortable and confident,
so when I have to perform,
I'm ready to go and I'm not anxious.
It was incredibly special to actually
achieve and win that World Cup.
Felt happy, felt ecstatic,
felt all of those great emotions,
but actually the biggest emotion
that came through was relief.
Because we spent 12 years
building up to that point,
We'd lost two
World Cup finals prior to that.
If I'd won the World Cup
straight away with my team
it wouldn't have been that special.
It wouldn't have meant anything
if we haven't had that journey.